hello and welcome back to another
episode of face off i'm ben davies and i
will be the master of ceremony since
cabot phillips always took credit for
hosting our current champions show and
that champion is of course mr michael
knowles
it's so wonderful to be with you ben
thank you for having me on my own show
i'm very excited to defend what am i i'm
we've done about three of these i'm
three for three right now three and oh
wow
that is if our challenger has anything
to say about it and he is an anarchist a
blue jeans enthusiast and is probably
best known for being the greatest cash
cab contestant in history michael malus
here is the cash that they give you when
you are a cash cab winner
so i brought it and on the back it says
in him we trust
so i came prepared i'm wearing since
we're talking about dictators i'm
wearing the shirt i got at the dmz the
north side
oh my gosh and in north korean clothes
i'm a size large even though me and ben
shapiro could share wardrobe
malice came to play yeah and i've got a
lot of historical artifacts which i'll
be dropping throughout the episode i'm
terrified i the all the the three other
challengers at the beginning of this
show they were so easily vanquished i
have a true expert in dictators you you
never start a land war in asia you never
go up against a sicilian when death is
on the line and you never take on an
anarchist when you're talking about
dictators so i i feel like on behalf of
the jewish people i have to compensate
for ben and his disastrous performance
against an italian this is embarrassing
they made fun of me at shul
i'm not even playing and i'm nervous now
knowles has bested walsh on catholicism
dave rubin and pop culture benjamin
shapiro like you said in name dropping
famous quotes from dead guys and this
whole thing is like the seventh circle
of hell and now we will find out once
and for all who knows more random facts
about murderous psychopaths and
democratically elected officials this is
face-off famous dictators
i've been prepping a lot by reading
about lincoln all night
on that note michael i believe there's
something you'd like to say to our
fantastic audience i absolutely would
when you want to protect your country
from brutal killers when you want to
protect your home from all those bad
guys you got to check out ring
we'll have more from ring later so
pleased that ring is here to support
this show and to support you and your
safety but we'll get to that after we
get to some dictators
all right
question number one
as a child his brother characterized him
as having been sweet tempered while
fellow school pupils recalled him as
quote mediocre but pleasant he went to
school in paris france before returning
to his home country taking power and
killing one-fifth of the entire
country's population
this is easy he was a family man
went to school in paris france
you guys both done i think so all right
michael knowles to you
ho chi minh
no michael malus
correct answer is in fact pol pots
did i just do a racist microaggression
with my ho chi minh answer
not off to a good start
next up this one is uh from a different
period
he is credited with popularizing the
phrase quote the die is cast after his
action that officially set him on the
path to becoming dictator his reign as
complete dictator only officially lasted
less than a year before he was
assassinated and he had the most famous
side chick in human history
i could say arguably there's been a lot
of famous side chicks but i do think
this one is probably the most famous
that's true
all right malice
i didn't know so i brought matt walsh
[Laughter]
i think close
if i'm right it's close
julius caesar julius caesar's correct
right that's the italian kind of home
court advantage when i think dictator i
was thinking temporary okay fair yeah
next up
this dictator grew up orthodox catholic
and studied to be a priest
later he successfully robbed a bank and
his crew would kill an estimated 40
people in the escape
later he oversaw the deaths of 20 to 60
million people
who is this dictator
he was raised to be a priest robbed a
bank
robbed a bank and the death toll is
estimated to be between 20 and 60
million people
i can see you both working hard here
about 10 more seconds
all right malice
it's stalin
i also said stalin just because of the
numbers but i didn't know any of that
about him
and you guys want to see something cool
it is just
yeah so this is a death warrant
signed
by stalin's last executioner barrier
and it just speaks to how little human
life means in these countries where they
can't even waste good paper and good ink
to kill you in their judicial system so
you're saying that that's a a print a
reprint no it's not a print this is the
original death
death warrant signed by baria oh my
stalin's third and last of his
executioners man
what auction does one attend to get
auction to get us on ebay actually oh my
gosh wow
michael malus which one of these things
tipped you off was just the number count
did you know about the bank robbing
just this morning reading about stalin's
upbringing like on the can
because there's a book called um stalin
against the jews because towards the end
of his life he was going to initiate a
new holocaust but
the doctors that he had blamed for his
bad health because when you're 70 in a
lifelong smoker it's a conspiracy he was
torturing them uh and he was going to
start a new pogrom and then they had to
take them out of the torture chambers to
help him as he was dying from a stroke
wow not a great dude not a great
stallion yeah this one's a little longer
so buckle up you can write down your
answer as i'm reading this
as an avid reader and lover of
literature he had relationships with
three nobel prize winning writers due to
his busy schedule he reckoned that since
shaving took about 15 minutes of
someone's time every morning 5 000
minutes a year was a massive waste of
time that he could use doing more
important things and it was reported by
the inter-american human rights
commission and the wall street journal
that this dictator oversaw 166
executions by submitting them to medical
procedures of blood extraction this
blood was then sold to communist vietnam
at a rate of 50 dollars per pint with
the dual purpose of obtaining hard
currency and contributing to the viet
cong communist aggression
who was this dictator
all right knowles what you got well i'm
just going on the no shaving is it fidel
malice
that's that was my clue too the only
dictator could think of that with a
beard was castro yep it was the beard
fidel castro wow okay
that was the trickiest thing about
finding these questions like you can't
say anything overt but it's just the
small hints the subtle hints of the
beard often give them away it's crazy
most of them are clean shaven like
almost every dictator yeah very clean
shaven what's the score now 3-3 we have
a tied ball game gentlemen
all right all right here we go
at age 27 he had plastic surgery to look
like his grandfather his father claimed
he never defecated and he reportedly
keeps a quote pleasure squad of girls as
young as 13 and in 2016 alone he spent
3.5 million dollars on lingerie and
costumes for them
this guy is a dictator and also very
strange he's a he's a living dictator
obviously
i can't give him any hints like a
currently serving dictator don't give
him any hints that's not fair i am the
master of ceremony malice but you're
i'll try not to give hints
what is this the leg up program
[Laughter]
and he's
he's obvious he's heterosexual he's a
super straight obviously he's got all
this harem okay
let's start that music here okay all
right all right
michael malus
so you had a mistake in the question uh
the answer is kim jong-un um kim jong-il
never said he didn't defecate if you
read the north korean literature it says
when he's out in the field doing field
guidance he doesn't take the time to go
to the bathroom but americans are like
oh they're so crazy so it's a lot less
crazy than it sounds oh i thought the
quote was from a defector saying that
when he met him he's like oh he's
obviously lying he doesn't he does
actually go to the bathroom there's no
way a defector met him
that's that's a good see i knew i knew
you'd have a leg up especially on this
particular person well i wrote a book
about it with the greatest title of any
book possibly i've ever read yes i uh
i'm really ashamed i totally forgot
about the kim's
i wrote bashar assad like a jerk i just
figured you know his dad was invited he
comes from a political family that's
really lame
really here we have a book
that has been signed by his grandfather
the founder of north korea the eternal
leader
no the grandfather that's what i mean
the the grandfather the first guy don't
they still pretend he's like the deity
he's the president he's still the
president wow
that's that's impressive memorabilia i'm
more excited to see what malice is going
to bring out each question is like more
exciting to see who's going to win all
right
next up
this dictator killed his brother to
become leader and only has one recorded
military loss while in power this
dictator's nickname was quote the
scourge of god he waged war with a
dominant empire at the time just to win
a wife and during his rule it's
estimated that he killed three million
civilians before he eventually died of a
nosebleed after heavy drinking
say the first part again
he killed his brother to become leader
and only has one recorded military loss
while in power
he was called the scourge of god he
waged a war to win a wife
and he eventually dies died of a
nosebleed after a night of partying
i don't know really
really grasping at straws here all right
same here i'm guessing knolls was it
genghis khan
yeah malice that's what i put that's
what i put two it was the other guy
attila the hun
it was the hun
yep oh
my first one my first guess was romulus
because i was really really out of oh
that's smart that's a good guess because
technically i could have probably tried
to force the issue but
all right say i love you it'll be next
up this is a long one too so buckle up
at age 10 he was expelled from from a
religious boarding school for stabbing a
classmate in the hand and another
stabbing incident took place at his next
school he also admitted to knifing his
girlfriend in the arm while in power he
outlawed freemasonry exempted the clergy
from taxation cracked down on artificial
contraception campaigned for an
increased birth rate raised penalties
for abortion restricted nightlife
regulated women's clothing and ban
homosexual acts among adult men and
despite having many mistresses himself
he also puts it put in place harsh
penalties for adultery after his death
samples of his brain were taken and sent
to the united states for analysis with
the intention to prove a hypothesis that
syphilis was the cause of his insanity
but no evidence of syphilis was found
it's not vlad the impaler but it would
be fitting it would be very fitting yeah
very poetic all right to you mr knowles
all right this is i'm just this is not
correct but he sounds extremely catholic
so i don't know charlemagne
well no you he said united states and
that really made this tough
because so i had to guess although i
don't think this guy's a dictator at all
i just guessed rasputin
that's a that's a good guess it was
actually mussolini that was really yeah
oh i thought mussolini got dragged
through the streets after they hung him
upside down yeah yeah but his br this
was after the fact was his brain was
later sent to the united states to be
tested to see if it was syphilis that in
fact made him insane wow i also was kind
of surprised because he stole a bunch of
land from oh my god
so mussolini had an election where the
only choices were voting for him for yes
and he got like 98 percent
but it's just all so funny like if you
want to look like the good guy this
really isn't the way to do it
that's very impressive
i i also thought i mean
he took a bunch of land from the church
i'm surprised that he you know i guess
though he was a politician you know yeah
yeah he was at first at war with the
church and then he kind of made a
bargain later huh yep oh man i'm really
really upset i missed the mussolini
question now i feel like i'm totally
sunk i'm actually very shocked that both
you guys missed that one i thought one
of those would tip you off
all right on to the next
this dictator embraced the diversity of
his newly conquered territories he
passed laws declaring religious freedoms
for all and even gave tax exemptions for
places of worship
this dictator really loved women and a
recent historical genetics paper
reported results which indicated that
one in 200 men today are his direct
descendants he was responsible for the
deaths of as many as 4 40 million people
roughly 11
of the world's population at the time
all right you guys can show
what's the score four five malice
oh how many more
if we michael if you are you nervous
right now i'm shaking i'm absolutely
terrified how many more questions do i
have to to redeem myself i am not going
to say
i want this to go down to the wire okay
daily wire
if you do tie there is a bonus question
but i don't know if that will happen
okay okay
next up
this dictator was married four times
including to one of the country's most
popular movie stars
an expert on this dictator said
because of him quote there were several
dozen cases of ritual cannibalism
and it was not about just eliminating
your class enemy but devouring them end
quote
also this dictator killed an estimated
45 to 100 million of his own people
oh
there's ritual cannibalism
all right
all right what you got
now it's mao and the thing is they were
literally eating the rich in terms of
the rich were evil
[Laughter]
you shouldn't have given the death toll
that gives it away the death toll does
give it away when when i heard the
cannibalism i i was thinking of hirohito
you know they sometimes call him a
dictator but yeah he didn't you know he
doesn't he doesn't have that kind of
body count yeah this one did kind of
softball it but like the other would you
have gotten it if i didn't say the body
count michael i i still would have oh
well i guess both i wouldn't i still
would have lead leaned now but i would
have been much harder michael i believe
you need to thank someone
you know i do i gotta thank a lot of
people i'm very i'm a very grateful guy
i'm especially thankful to ring
ring an absolutely a wonderful service
you know i've been talking to you for
years about the ring video doorbell
that's where you can see and speak to
whoever's at your door wherever you are
in the world that's cool what about the
ring alarm what about not just the ring
alarm to protect your windows in your
doors and your whole physical space but
what about the ring alarm pro are you
like me do you want to go pro cnet calls
ring alarm pro a giant leap for home
security you're going to be away from
your home this summer you're going to be
going on vacation you're going to want
to protect your physical home your
digital home your entire family well
that's why you need to get ringo to
ring.com knowles that's ring.com
k-n-o-w-l-e-s
and keep out all the elements and all
the bad guys
all right on to the next dictator under
his reign perverse methods of torture
were used including murder stoning
crucifixions drowning forcing the
ingestion of lead bearing inmates alive
and tying naked victims around barrels
surrounded by nails he died after having
killed an estimated 3 million of his own
people and his body was embalmed and as
of 2022 his body remains on public
display
can you read that again
the the murderous stuff or just the
stuff about the people that he killed
the the stuff about what he did to like
his victims so the methods that he used
allegedly are
stoning crucifixions drowning forcing
the ingestion of lead burying inmates
alive and tying naked victims around
barrels surrounded by nails
and his body still on display
yeah his body was embalmed and as of
2022 his body remains on public display
okay
all right see it
is it a lemon
yeah the only dictator the only two
dictators i know of that are on display
are lenin and kimmel sung and kim
jong-il yep lennon i think stan is still
in bomb right isn't he on display no
stalin's in the car the wall the kremlin
wall uh okay wait so lenin crucified
people
apparently according to no he didn't
this is not true yeah i don't buy this i
don't buy this for a second the thing
with this is i i'm doing a book right
now about the soviet union and i know
they're tortures and crucifixion that
would be completely an obscenity in
their ideology well our brand new fact
checker the daily wires me very very
disappointed when he hears that yeah
what they did
was they would tie someone's um wrists
and ankles behind them and hang them
like that until the sockets popped out
but that's not crucifixion yeah that's
yeah i guess it's way better right i
guess our brand new fact checker will
have a good time and our soon-to-be
brand new producer who's going to find
these facts is going to have an even
better time so that's great
this is fake news from the lying daily
wire
which is failing badly
yeah but the uh the lying naked on you
know barrels that's about the
crucifixion you know that we can't
actually
do that to this guy that wouldn't
possibly do that yeah
all right next up this person was a
gambling fan which is somewhat odd given
they were so religious
this was one of the few rulers who never
had a child and this person was
responsible for over 300 religious
dissenters being burned at the stake in
what is known as the marian persecution
i'm standing sorry i'll find my friend
um
all right malice you're up
i had no idea that's what charlemagne
really
this is you know you're going to kick
yourself because he he accidentally or
unwittingly said it at the end he said
it's the marian persecutions mary the
first of england
queen mary the first bloody mary bloody
mary i'd never even heard of her she's
not a dictator first of all she was a
wonderful queen of england and the
protestant who chose these questions is
obviously tilting the scales but anyway
if it gets me the point i'll take what i
can get yeah it is tough using google to
find like the worst dictators in history
because it just comes up like george
bush donald trump and like you know
sitting through it mary was the only
woman that was really popular yeah by
the way that's not true we have hillary
clinton
and this is a signed copy of her book it
takes a village so there are other women
dictators that's the i'm now going to
advocate book burnings i think the
you know that sometimes people say that
queen mary's
uh attacks on the on the 300 dissenters
that that was a you know a horrible
example of religious persecution you
know what i say it is a good start
that's what i say
all right on that note
this next dictator lost two fingers by
way of arrow after he tried to steal a
sheep from a shepherd
it is estimated that this ruler was
responsible for 17 million deaths a
staggering five percent of the world's
population at the time
allegedly his coffin read
whoever opens my tomb shall unleash an
invader more terrible than i
hitler invaded the ussr within two days
of the excommunication of the coffin and
when the tomb was finally reburied the
soviet union of the soviet victory at
stalingrad shortly followed
wait repeat that last part about hitler
please
after his coffin which read whoever
opens my tomb shall unleash an invader
more terrible than i hitler invaded the
ussr and with within two days of the
exhumation and when his tomb was finally
reburied the soviet victory at
stalingrad shortly followed
i really have no idea
there's
two
i've heard this story before but i don't
i just don't have any
okay i'm guessing
all right what you got
i'm guessing kaiser wilhelm
i said ivan the terrible because i don't
know he's got a good name both wrong it
was timur
man
never heard of him that guy was a maniac
that guy built towers out of human heads
of his victims that guy was a complete
lunatic oh wow you know what they call
that a good start
yeah of all the dictators i that i
discovered in this process this guy was
the worst and most unknown of all of
them like yeah very few people know this
guy that guy is truly he was he was the
creme de la creme of psychopaths he
truly was i'm sorry i'm sorry i missed
that
all right next up it's been reported
that this dictator hated visiting the
dentist dental exams were like a phobia
to him thus it's also reported that he
suffered from gum disease and extremely
bad breath he was twice rejected from
attending art school and afterwards
ended up living on the streets it is
estimated that this dictator and his
regime is responsible for over 20
million non-battle deaths
all right throw it up i'm gonna say
mr hitler
hitler
do you guys want to see something really
cool oh no i was waiting for this
okay so here's ava braun's locket yeah
this is one of his books
from his bunker
i'm not going to show you the book plate
for obvious reasons but the fact that it
is now owned by a jew from the soviet
union and american that's three strikes
against adolf but i'm not joking
blaire white has also rubbed her
genitals on this
so this is a real big screw you to adolf
oh my gosh
michael where where did you get that
there is a book called the last archives
of the fewer bunker some guy stole a
bunch of it and a bunch of it went on
auction last month in belgium so i got
three items so you just got this is
within a month oh my gosh
that is amazing i'm just i'm frankly i'm
just glad that when ben was reading that
he said you know
whatever it was 20 million uh you know
deaths broadly or whatever you didn't
start because when he starts he starts
disputing all the numbers and everything
and it's just he really it's very ugly
what he does he does
stop it i'm just kidding
why is he in jail i know
[Applause]
all right next up annoyed by his sick
nephew's cough this dictator had the
child beheaded and later told his sister
that quote he cured the cough
it's also been said that he sent his
troops on illogical military exercises
and turned his palace into a brothel
his favorite line was quote remember i
have the right to do anything to anybody
and maybe most famously he planned or
promised to make his horse a council and
even appointed a priest to serve the
horse come on nols you got this yeah say
the first part again sorry ben annoyed
got it annoyed by his sick nephew's
cough this dictator had the child
beheaded and later told his sister that
he quote cured the cough
he also said that he's it's also been
said that he sent his troops on
illogical military exercises and turned
his palace into a brothel his favorite
line was quote remember i have the right
to do anything to anybody unquote and
maybe most famously he planned or
promised to make his horse a council and
even appointed a priest to serve this
horse
do you know this
yeah of course this is this is
one-on-one stuff you don't know this
what no i don't actually i ah i want to
say something so bad
don't say anything you've given him
enough help yeah i uh
ten seconds nols
how embarrassing for you
yeah all right whatever man i know dave
rubin this is beautiful
[Laughter]
all right i don't yeah i don't all right
mallet
it's caligula caligula oh
that's
the thing with the horse is it's not as
crazy as it sounds he just wanted like a
second vote is my understanding
oh was that okay did you write that's
actually i just wrote i only write ivan
the terrible if i don't know what it is
that's real and i write one song that's
awful oh man i missed caligula
he's probably
what people would say are is the most
evil dictator from what i can tell from
doing google and wikipedia he was pretty
bad yeah
he's nowhere near as bad as hitler and
mao well of course that's left-wing
stuff when you're searching like you
know on google or whatever that's what
you'll get is that caligula was the most
maybe the most crazy but he didn't kill
a lot of people yeah yeah there were
fewer people i guess but no but even
proportionately he wasn't like this
butcher yeah no he was just just a nut
there's a lot of people that died i
deleted some of that stuff all right
next up
this dictator named a city he founded
after his horse another horse lover this
dictator is said to have severed the
gordian knot he also famously never lost
a battle only stopped conquering
territory after his army demanded that
they turn around and go home
all right show it
alexander the great xander alexander the
great that is correct
alexandria it's also the worst movie
ever made after him
that's fair all right next up
this dictator wrote a best-selling
romance novel i wonder if michael
actually has this on his shelf i don't
but i know who it is
we got four more clues or three more
clues after his daughters fled to mary
this dictator tricked them to return
home with promises of forgiveness before
he tortured and killed both his
son-in-laws after a small attack on his
motorcade was put down this dictator had
over 400 of the attackers friends and
family members tortured and put to death
he also hated fruit loops
wait crap it's one of two people and i'm
blanking on which one
he they fled to mary
yeah they fled with i guess he did not
approve of who they chose and then he
tricked him into coming back and then
killed him immediately like mary like
the mother of god no no like to wed
oh to mary oh yeah the a was was not it
was not pronounced correctly english is
my second language
they fled to yeah okay you know you're a
catholic but you're here to marry yeah
this is the first place your head goes i
don't okay hold on i actually i actually
do think i know this one gosh i don't
know i've heard this story but
malice looks pretty confident
i got 50 50 on this one i
i don't know all right mouse what you
got i thought i put saddam hussein yeah
i put saddam it's saddam hussein is it
yeah it is oh man i almost you can see i
started to write mubarak and i was like
nah but like same region and then saddam
wow okay that's good right
this one's a long one too
my adrenaline is through the roof right
yeah yeah
all right
since he was born from a second marriage
for the sole purpose of his father
conceiving an heir a local priest
predicted that quote
out of this evil deed an evil child will
be born unquote he is credited with
creating what is believed to be the
first secret police of the time who were
given complete immunity for the actions
they took
in one infamous account his lawless
force tortured and killed up to 60
thousand innocent civilians many of whom
were tied to sleds and pushed into icy
rivers for sport
this dictator later died while playing
chess
oh gosh okay i'm guessing
can for producing an heir
his father had a wife and she could not
bear children so he divorced her and
took another woman so he could have an
heir which was illegal at the time
all right you ready
i hope you stuck with your guns knowles
i did not no
henry henry the eighth nope that's who
you got ishmael i don't know i've been
the terrible no no are you kidding me
guys
like after all this oh my god that's
beautiful unbelievable
i went i thought it was a funny answer
what would have been the clue
the the chess or the uh the frozen
rivers like that's brutal what did i
know
when you said illegal at the time i
thought the whole point of henry viii
founding the anglican church was to
allow divorce that was what
led me
apparently i don't even know what area
this was where ivan was born but it was
a very religious area and the
they were not allowed to have divorce
you know the problem i'll tell you the
reason i didn't i didn't get it i don't
know anything about ivan the terrible i
just i've been kind of bluffing you know
okay
all right here we go
this leader divorced his first wife
because she could not bear him a son
he survived the first ever assassination
by bomb attempt which killed 40 people
but not its target
he was one of the few leaders to be
removed from power
but ra and was not killed but rather
died of natural causes after being
banished
i thought that was going to be a henry
the eighth kind of layup you know
you want to read any of these again yeah
read the whole thing again all right
this leader divorced his first wife
because she could not bear him a son
he survived the first ever assassination
attempt by bomb which killed 40 people
but missed its target
he was one of the few leaders to be
removed from power twice and not killed
rather he died of natural causes after
being banished 10 seconds
you all both done yeah i guess all right
show them
i'm guessing henry viii napoleon it's
napoleon hey oh yeah yeah
it was the it was the bomb i felt it
would be more more uh current and uh the
banishment
that was the only that was the only
giveaway i knew if i so that's a good
clue the banishment elba yeah yeah yeah
if i said saint helena i would have
given it away right yeah okay all right
so are we are we tied again you are not
going to believe this gentleman this is
the first ever tie on face off
which means
thank goodness this morning my way in i
have a bonus card with two very very
important questions what if we both get
them right or it's like one in one what
if we just tie it again again there's no
way what about the third question i do i
actually have a backup but there's no
way this is going to be a tie okay okay
you're going to try to get as close to
this number as possible this million
get as close to this dictator's body
count as possible are you ready okay
what is the current clinton body count
so you can get the closest to the most
widely accepted number okay among
scholars yeah a scholar yeah uh we're
not including like him bombing the
pharmaceutical factory you mean like
people he's alleged to have murdered
right right
okay that's an important distinction
actually it is though yeah iraq too i
mean yeah this is so great i cannot
believe we got to this bonus question
wow i'm i'm pleased about that uh
is it is it hold on before we is it the
closest without going over or is it the
absolute closest
we'll do the absolute closest yeah
all right
oh i can't wait
all right
show it
i guess 70. i wrote 108.
it is 186. michael nolan is the champion
once again wow
oh my gosh that is great i can't believe
we got to that
oh man
i
first of all 186 that's awesome second
of all i it's a good start
i really thought
i'd ivan the terrible that was it i had
i had given up my
so that's it i win that's it you win oh
my gosh as the victor the victor knows
the spoils which means michael malus
will read a 30-second pitch for why
people should listen to the michael
knowles show that was the
not only the most formidable challenge
we've ever seen on this show that was
the most my heart has beaten that was
the most adrenaline that's pumped
through my veins and
that was very very impressive and the
the memorabilia are
out of this world
my heart was racing faster than anne
frank during the day oh jeez
i could say it you can say it you can
say it and you own the book so you can
no that's fair
michael thank you for coming on ben
thank you for inviting me on to my own
show oh of course it's so good to have
you michael knowles and michael mouse
before we leave is there any more
memorabilia that we didn't get to that
you want to show the audience
yes and i'm surprised you didn't ask a
question about him
because we have here i guess in daley
wire terms he's not a dictator i have a
book an english book by pinochet and it
is signed by him what
right there
did was this also like ebay or something
or did would it have this was uh just
that books uh like a bookstore had it
consigned
yeah yeah yeah
awesome so i i love that the absolute
proof that according the daily wired
pinochet did nothing wrong yeah no of
course absolutely now if you had some
allende stuff there that would be
different but yeah yeah well before we
go michael mouse will you please give us
a 30 second pitch to the audience of why
people should listen to the michael
knowles show
michael knowles is one of the most
original intelligent voices in
podcasting today he always has guests
where he asks innovative questions and
has intelligent conversations rather
than focusing on talking points and
yelling past each other it's a great way
to listen to right of center points of
view while at the same time having a
host who is charismatic and collegial to
his guests
wow that was
that was the first time any of those
have ever been nice and sincere and not
mean that was thank you that was very
nice but i lost fair and square you did
now
i you and so you get another point over
walsh and ben and dave and all those
jerks who gave me backhanded compliments
that i really that was very sweet that's
like being the tallest dwarf
well thank you so much michael well
there you have it please write in the
comments section and let us know who
you'd like to see and what topic you
want to cover in the next episode of
faceoff
[Music]
[Music]